you know Mobility is is really the
ability to be able to move freely
through your environment and do the
things you want to be able to do with
your body whatever those things may be
now we we offer a lot of tools which we
call mobilizations which are things you
can do to help improve your mobility and
range of motion ideally without pain or
at least minimizing pain and feel to do
the things you love to do the problem is
that we don't give people
benchmarks for what is normative or what
you should be able to do and our lives
sometimes don't ask us of that and so
suddenly when we have pain or a problem
that range of motion is never part of
the conversation about hey I see that
your steering wheel doesn't go all the
way to the left so we could also Define
mobility as do you have your native
range of motion and can you control that
native range of motion really what is it
you want to do in your world and
environment how do you want to express
this body that's the most important
thing